welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and thor love and thunder released
a batch of official posters giving us
some interesting insights of what
taikawati has in store for this movie
including some recurring symbolism that
recontextualizes some mysterious shots
from the trailer and yeah why this movie
seems a bit obsessed with the cast's
anatomy i mean so are we based on the
youtube metrics showing what part of the
may trailer viewers re-watch the most i
mean look at that bulge also the sun
view increase but i suspect something
deeper is going on here intentional by
the filmmakers and thanks to true bill
for sponsoring today's video more about
them later okay thor levine thunder
released 11 new posters including seven
character posters from the studio and
then an imax poster a realty 3d poster a
dolby poster and a screen x poster but
before we dig into these we really
should talk about how unusual the
marketing for thor love and thunder has
been for marvel studios other phase four
theatrical releases after theaters
reopened post pandemic shutdowns
including shangchi eternals and doctor
strange in the multiverse madness i'm
including spiderman no way home because
sony did the marketing for that not
disney marvel but for those other mcu
titles marvel studios followed a proven
playbook a teaser trailer five months
out a more revelatory trailer with new
footage two months out and then in the
final month a final promo when tickets
go on sale followed by near daily tv
spots and social media promos teasing
bits and pieces of new footage until the
release thorough love and thunder has
taken a different path its first trailer
broke records for the closest the
release date the studio had waited to
release its first teaser its successive
promos have shown limited new footage
each one resampling guns n roses sweet
child of mine in little revealed beyond
here's a guy who wants to kill gods for
some reason and the plot detail that the
comics are most known for jane foster's
cancer show nowhere in any of the
footage now to be clear i actually love
this as a fan like i prefer when
trailers don't reveal too much i think
we knew way too much going into
multiverse madness from professor x to
captain carter to most of the alternate
universes visited in that movie shown
ahead of time in promos i know it seems
like my life here at new rockstars is
feasting on trailer footage but to be
honest there's always plenty of us to
talk about regardless of how much a
studio wants to market its movie so as a
follower of the film industry i just
find it interesting from a marketing
standpoint marvel studios marketing is
really part of their narrative process
every marvel movie is really the second
act of a three-act event act one the
hype leading up to a movie act two the
movie itself and then act three the
post-credit scene and the celebration
thereafter so strategic reveals are
always built into trailers in order to
build hype so that the must-see
word-of-mouth shockwave spreads to the
second weekend in the third weekend
audiences which by then the studio hopes
to have recouped its production
marketing costs and then begin to purely
profit kids and families are more likely
to see movies in the second and third
weeks they are really the ones who buy
the most toys and merchandise which is
where disney makes most of its money
from this ip let's be honest this is all
to sell toys so really it's a major
prerogative of disney for these titles
to not just come and go like typical
summer action movies but really for them
to be eight week media events that
blanket social media and advertising
channels now one could argue that with
thor eleven thunder this particular cast
and crew requires less of a height
machine i mean if you're watching this
video you're probably gonna see this
movie anyway you didn't need a trailer
to tell you that but despite that marvel
studios rarely takes that risk the
trailers aren't just for you and me it's
for like your brother-in-law or your
cousin who might not see a marvel movie
otherwise they're the ones disney is
counting on to see these movies and so
the hype machine is really essential
like think about it the hype between
infinity war and in-game was already at
peak frenzy they didn't need to release
trailers for that but they still did and
they were very strategic about it they
spared no way expense and if you
remember back to march 2019 april 2019
there were constant promos for that
movie and they played a huge role in
making end game the biggest movie of all
time and the end game marketing also
proved that you can hype the hell out of
a movie without your promo spoiling
anything remember endgame promos
revealed nothing about the time heist
about smart hulk fat thor or any of the
final battle highlights so the
withholding of trailer footage really
doesn't have that much to do with
avoiding spoiling a movie you could
still show a lot of a movie and then use
things like deceptive editing and vfx to
avoid spoiling anything and really the
marketing for thor 11 thunder seems
scaled in even in comparison to thor
ragnarok which opened with the teaser
set to lead zeppelin's immigrant song
seven months out and then at a media
trailer at comic-con four months before
the release with different music all new
footage mostly and then a full marketing
blitzkrieg in october 2017. so as an
outside observer who reads way too much
in immediate budgets and news cycles one
might conclude that disney might have
overspent its second quarter marketing
budget on multiverse of madness got a
little pushback for revealing too much
in those movies trailers and now just
seems to have shifted to an overall less
is more strategy for thor love and
thunder all of this is a way of saying
thor love and thunder has a few big
things up in sleeve that it does not
want to show in the marketing for the
film for a mix of narrative and
marketing reasons and these new posters
god bless them begin to get at why but i
gotta ask you are you saving up for a
big trip this summer or maybe you're
looking to do some projects around the
house that require you to have a little
extra cash on hand or perhaps you just
want to save a little extra for your
future well truebill is here to help
truebill is an all-in-one finance
platform that helps you save more and
spend less the personal finance manager
allows you to manage subscriptions lower
bills monitor your credit score and
build your savings all in one place
several of us here at new rockstars have
used drewbill to help us better manage
our finances truebill has helped
offscreen producer brandon cancel
unwanted subscriptions by safely and
securely identifying recurring charges
and canceling those unwanted
subscriptions with just a tap no need to
try to hunt down the cancel button on a
complicated website truebill does all
the hard work for you also by simply
uploading a photo and tapping a button
truebill can negotiate your bills for
you from internet service bills to cable
and phone bills they also monitor your
credit score truebill will alert you of
important charges that impact your score
and offers you insights on ways to
improve it they do all of this and so
much more most importantly it is safe to
use trubil does not store your online
banking credentials and it does not sell
your information to anyone to try trubil
out for free and unlock more features
with premium head to truebill.com new
rockstars or click the link in the video
description marvel studios released
seven character posters each one with a
similar background of waterfalls over a
nordic fjord with lightning striking
through and a planet with a moon in the
sky behind them one for thor odinson one
for mighty thor jane foster one for gore
one for valkyrie one for korg one for
zeus and one for thor's goats tooth
nasher and tooth grinder these goats can
also be seen pulling thor's viking boat
in all the posters except one gore's
where the background sky is particularly
red then there are four more posters one
for imax one for realty 3d one for dolby
and one for screen x and the imax poster
also features this looming planet behind
them but no moon which might mean that
currently in the foreground they are
standing on that moon and on this
landscape on the left and the right side
are just some interesting curved statue
pieces suggesting that this is some
setting that we will see in the movie so
is the planet just cosmic background
decor for the poster art maybe but
footage for thor love and thunder also
keeps coming back to this lonely planet
once seen through a ripped in space that
a crag floats into another shot of
thor's boat floating toward a planet
whose surface seems to ice over as he
approaches a shot of a moon getting
broken apart from blue lightning and
various shots of gore and valkyrie and
thor fighting on a desaturated broken
lunar landscape and i keep getting hung
up on gore saying in a recent promo
and the fact that he just uses a
singular world in that sentence and that
this guy is pronounced a vow to kill all
gods just make me wonder if gore is not
so much of a kamikaze force but more of
a religious revolutionary we might be
interested in constructing his own world
his own planet outside of the
jurisdiction of the marvel gods that
could be the world much of this movie
takes place on in a setting that they
don't really show too much of in
marketing material hinted at in the art
of these posters now the real d3d poster
is just a shot of thor's arm focusing on
his tattoo thor's inc seems to be of
particular importance to this movie's
plot or at least something the
filmmakers expect us to be interested in
you'll remember in the trailer zoos
flicks off its disguise and we see
thor's back covered in tattoos including
r.i.p loki there's also a tattoo of a
broken heart which i'm pretty sure
represents his heartbreak over jane and
yeah coming back to that other detail
left out of almost all the marketing is
the fact that jane foster in the story
has cancer coming from jason aaron's
mighty thor comics natalie portman
confirmed this in one interview with
yahoo back in 2020 and not once since
now i get it cancer is a bit of a downer
but hey cancer did not stop the fault in
our stars from beating tom cruise at the
box office in 2014 audiences are not
afraid of cancer being in their movies
but i think it is being left out of the
marketing because jane's health is a
reason why she broke up with thor and
that reveal might be something they want
to say for the movie it's just me
speculating i have not seen the movie
yet obviously but portman also confirmed
in an interview with d23 magazine that
this film will flash back to why she and
thor broke up a bit of a mystery
throughout phase three and maybe we're
gonna learn that prolonged exposure
between a human and an asgardian is
something no human body is really
designed to handle maybe even a barrier
put in place between tears of godly
status in the marvel universe by the
cosmic beings to keep these tears
separate a cruel thing to do but hey
god's mating with humans as zeus has
proved throughout greek mythology leads
to a bit of chaos this could be why thor
is now with the guardians to stay as far
away from jane as possible and before
you say well wouldn't the guardians be
exposed no none of them are just normal
humans even peter quill is the son of a
celestial he could hold an infinity
stone without a destroying his body he'd
be less harmed by thor's toxic exposure
this could also be why thor is now
surprised and delighted to see jane
elevated to his godly status he finally
has a chance to be with her so what do
you think is it gore's secret world or
jane's cancer which do you think is a
likelier reason behind thor 4's weird
marketing is the marketing not that
weird i'm overthinking it probably what
i'm just saying it's someone who covers
a lot of this stuff there is something
different about the marketing on this
movie it's subtle but it is different i
assume we will all know why on the other
side of this movie's release but in the
meantime you can follow me on instagram
and twitter at ea boss following
rockstars subscribe to rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you